Today, we're learning English with another
lesson from the Harry Potter legacy!
Are you ready? This movie will help us learn
more about young Dumbledore, played by Jude Law,
as well as his relationship with Grindelwald
and how this affects the war between them.
But before we start, each week we release lessons
to help intermediate and advanced learners like
you improve your English in a fun and dynamic way,
without getting lost, without missing the jokes and
without needing subtitles. So if you're new here
make sure that you join our community of over
5 million learners by hitting the subscribe
button and the bell down below right now!
When learning a new language it can be a huge
challenge trying to figure out which words and
expressions are important and which ones you may
never need. Without the guidance of a good teacher
you could waste a lot of time learning the wrong
ones. But don't worry, because with our Fluent with
Friends course you can learn words and expressions
that native speakers actually use every day.
Plus you'll have tons of fun doing it with the TV
series Friends which various academic studies have
proven is the best show to learn English! In this
course you will also learn how native speakers
reduce, cut and connect sounds which is the secret
to understanding us no matter how fast we speak.
You can try it now for free with our
3-part Masterclass. So what are
you waiting for? Simply click up here or down
in the description box below to sign up now!
If you enjoyed today's lesson
then I definitely recommend that you
check out this one next! Let's watch!